let's go to Casey from Kansas Casey from
Kansas welcome to the program what can I
do for you today hello
uh just you know more heavy stuff given
the recent you know
shooting that happened yeah
so Tucker Carlson recently had a segment
called
trans killer the trans movement is
targeting Christians following the
Nashville shooting do you think
journalism quotation marks that fear
monger's marginalized groups with such a
broad brush
should be illegal
in a way oh man what Germany are other
European countries would have well
there's a number of questions there
because first of all you're using
journalism in quotes legally Tucker
Carlson doesn't do journalism he does
commentary so then the question is a
broader one which is
can can you know so it's more like in
the category of this might be satire
this might be sensationalism this is it
is the I think we really need legal
experts to weigh in on what even could
be done before we can even really weigh
in as to what should be done because
it's such a difficult question to answer
but I know exactly what you're saying
which and and listen
scapegoating is not a new technique
right now the trans Community is being
heavily scapegoated from all around I
hope it doesn't last forever but of
course when it goes away they'll move on
to the next group but you're asking some
really complicated questions that we
really need the legal world to answer to
answer for us excuse me
okay yeah I I don't know I wish there
was just something that could be done
because you know they call themselves
Fox News and they make it seem like
there's a little bit of credibility when
there's really none but then they get
sued and then they go oh listen Tucker
Carlson's an Entertainer he uses
Hyperbole and exaggeration and blah blah
blah you can't hold them accountable
nobody should believe that what he says
is factual that's under oath in court
what they say and then on TV they
pretend like it's news now I'm with you
Casey
okay well that's all I had all right
Casey from Kansas great to hear from you
that is all the time I have for today
great to hear from a lot of new and
repeat callers we will take calls again
and I look forward to hearing from many
more of you